today we're a data-driven society data
of different companies data drives all
of our lives and being able to
understand that data and you find kind
of gems of insight in that data and even
more being able to communicate
effectively with data is more important
today than it's ever been having tools
that help people do that that's I think
one of the big challenges that we face
right now sand dance is a data
visualization system that lets people
explore data find the insights in that
data and communicate those insights with
others there's a great data set that
looks at demographic information in the
United States it looks at the levels of
education income in all the counties
typically you'd think that the greater
the education you have in a county the
more income there would be in the
Bentley and that's often true that's the
overall trend but I found this kind of
weird outlier and the the the highest
education at least according to the
percentage of the people that had a
bachelor's degree or more actually had a
very low income level I looked at where
it was it was Stanford California kind
of made sense that they were working on
their higher degrees not getting paid
much but then I looked at other outliers
that were just like that it turns out
that every single one of these places
that had high education levels but low
income every one of was a college town
20 of them all these points they're all
out there and I thought that was really
interesting I never would have looked at
before but when I saw the pattern the
data I found that a lot of the people
that look at data visualization systems
tend to be data analysts but I think
there's a much wider audience out there
I think that people that are fans of
kind of understanding patterns in
society and looking
economic trends or political trends or
or anything really I think there's a
very wide audience that can take these
applications if they're made easy enough
and compelling enough